tonight's show contains scenes of a
graphic nature which may not be suitable
for younger viewers parental discretion
is advised
last night on Conan O'Brien I'm sorry I
missed your birthday darling I was
making love to your sister you bastard
give me one good reason why I should
sell out to you Andy but we have your
daughter you bastard
strong arms I like that in a man
what would a young virile man like that
seeing an old bag like you can't do this
to me you can't too late old friend I
already have this
I'm Conan O'Brien not anymore you're not
he is
[Music]
I thought you might like to meet your
daughter
[Music]
you're working for darling it's so
extravagant it's nothing really my wife
will never miss it
is your spinning days are over
[Music]
get rid of him and have the pool clean
did you put in my in my coffee take a
nap drummer boy where were you last
night with your brother
you know he's a much better lover than
you are you bastard
you can't leave me I own you
guess again
[Music]
okay O'Brien put the gun down I don't
think so the hell is this
if no one else will stop you I will
recon
[Music]
I don't know nothing about that you
don't know anything we'll see about that
[Music]